موسكو نامت على صوره زيننسكي وهو يتبادل
التحايا مع الرئيس الامريكي والاكثر من
ذلك عوده غانما بحزمه مساعدات جديده لن
تزيد الحرب الا استحقا الكلام انتقد
الزياره حتى قبل وصول زيننسكي الى واشنطن
بل بمجرد اقلاع طائرته من بولندا حيث قال
ان في زياره تجاهل واضحا للمخاوف الروسيه
واتهم الكرملين واشنطن بالمشاركه المباشره
في هذه الحرب هذه الزياره تاريخيه الى
الولايات المتحده ساره قات الانظار حتى من
التطورات الميدانيه حيث تركزت الاعين على
واشنطن لترسد مشاهد الرئيس الاوكراني وهو
يكرر استحالفه مع الولايات المتحده ردود
الفعل توالت لكن كيف تفعلت الصحف العالميه
مع هذا الحدث
مجله نيوزبيك شدت على ان زياره زيلينز في
جاءت في توقيف جيد كما انها اشاره الى ان
تعمل امريكي لا يزال قويا اما صحيفه نيوز
ويك ان نيويورك تايمز عفوا فقد وصفت زياره
الى الولايات المتحده تاكيدا على وحده
البلدين في مواجهه الهجوم الروسي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]